welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and with the
captured just wrapping up its first
season I thought I'd take a closer look
at the show and its ending to breakdown
if everything is as it appears or if
there's been some Corrections throughout
this video I'll be recapping the entire
first season of the capture as well as
discussing the true meaning behind its
ending and where the show could go in
the future
there will be heavy spoilers here so if
you haven't had a chance to watch all
six episodes yet and don't want to know
what happens then I highly recommend
that you turn off now without the way I
just want to give a huge thank you for
clicking this video now let's get into
our breakdown of the capture the capture
follows Sean Emory an ex soldier who was
jailed after apparently shooting an
enemy combatant in cold blood during an
excursion in Afghanistan though Sean
denied this he was found guilty because
of video and audio evidence that was
submitted in his trial
that apparently showcased him carrying
out the Act however Sean was later
acquitted during his appeal due to the
fact that the video and audio may have
been victim to a technical fault that
causes audio over time to unsink from a
source at its heart the capture is about
how in the modern age we really contrast
technology the show is laced with the
subtext that deep fakes photoshop's and
video editing have all grown to a point
where we really can no longer say that
the camera never lies
Sean once more finds himself victim to
this when CCTV footage of him emerges
attacking his barrister Hannah Roberts
and when her body turns up things look
bad for the character season 1 of the
capture follows Sean as he tries to
unearth the truth behind who framed him
and there are some awesome twists and
turns at every point that really keep
the narrative engaging throughout season
1 sean is aided by Detective Inspector
Rachel Kerry who slowly begins to
uncover the conspiracy behind it all and
we discover that there is a government
organization known as correction that
conduct a live CCTV footage in order to
plant evidence that will eventually lead
to convictions correction move in a
morally gray area where the
state that they only do it to people
that they know are guilty but can't use
evidence such as wiretaps and
surveillance in court so they are forced
to create evidence that will lead to the
jailing of the wrongdoers
it's the modern-day version of policemen
putting the murder weapon in a suspects
home and even by the close of the show
the audience will be questioning if they
are really helping or hindering people
the show examines our own society and
asks the question is it wrong to frame
someone if you know they're guilty which
makes for a fascinating watch they're
basically Mysterio and far from home but
without a cool cape anyway when Sean
comes face-to-face with correction that
they deny all knowledge of their
involvement and actually turns out that
Hanna Roberts and a team had faked the
abduction and did this in the hopes that
once people learn the truth about
correction and their ability to all the
evidence that those who were wrongly
convicted would be able to finally get a
fair trial they wanted to do this once
more with Sean to show that he was
innocent and that the system was corrupt
correction learned of this and were
forced to kill Hannah in order to make
it look like Sean really did it so that
their processes would remain a secret
the capture is a really complex
storyline that will definitely keep you
on your toes
and the show actually avoided a lot of
cliches that I was expecting as we
eventually got to the final episode it
all came to a head in episode 6 when
both British and American intelligence
finally caught up to Sean and
blackmailed him into taking the blame
for Hannah's murder he didn't really
have a choice and the government group
stated that if he didn't take the fall
willingly then they would use their
technology which had advanced to the
point of 3d modeling to make him look
even worse at his trial as Sean pleaded
guilty and was convicted for the murder
with diminished responsibility though
footage made its way to the web like
many other things that hit the Internet
it was labeled as a conspiracy theory
and brush to the side meaning that Sean
will indeed be spending a large chunk of
his life behind bars it's a real gut
punch however we do discover in the
finale that the portrayal of Sean
himself in his own mind had in some ways
been edited by the character due to his
admission that he did indeed kill a
soldier in Afghanistan and was therefore
a criminal similar to correction in his
mind he corrected the circumstances so
that he would believe he was a bear
purse
he stated he'd lied so much that he
didn't even know the truth anymore and
it was a really poignant reveal that
showed that the series is full of shades
of grey rather than just being simply
black and white Rachel who similar to
Shawn had learned the truth of
correction was stuck in a moral quandary
as she discovered that one of the
convictions that led to her promotion
was due to the software she liked Shawn
was morally blackmailed into keeping it
to herself as she realized that should
the truth be unearthed many criminals
would be able to launch appeals and all
video evidence in every trial ever could
be put under closer scrutiny
thus killers may walk free and so on she
eventually joined anti-terrorism aware
of what will be going on and the
wrongful convictions and corrections
that she would be a part of and well
many may believe that she took a full
turn to the dark side due to her
ambition there is the possibility that
she may be working with them in order to
expose them Rachel takes a copy of the
real footage of Shawn and Hannah perhaps
to overturn his conviction should she
need to this was backed up by series
writer Ben Shannon who when speaking to
Metro on the character's decision said
the following I think Kerry joining them
at the end is a moral tragedy she's
deciding it's best for her in every
sense to go along with it it could be
life-threatening to her but it could
also enhance her need to know the truth
about things and this is where the truth
is revealed there is ambiguity about
what she's going in there for and I'm
going to leave that there so there
definitely is a possibility that she
could be getting close to correction in
order to expose it even correction
themselves didn't get away from the
series scot-free and we watched in the
finale as Frank Napier played by Ron
Perlman pretty much became ostracized by
his superior Jessica played by funky
Anson who'd been sent in to clean up his
mess going forward I think that he may
be left better by the entire process
especially after he's pretty much given
up his life to do the job and to be cast
aside like this would put anyone in a
bad mood
perhaps in season two he will join
Rachel to reveal the truth behind
correction as the season finale heavily
teases that they are lining up him in
the crosshairs - I guess we will see
going forward but with season two now
rumored to be greenlit things could be
getting a whole lot more complex in the
future and that's the capture
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on it and what you want to see in a
second season comment below and let me
know and if you enjoy this video then
please like it and make sure you check
out my ending explain breakdown of last
week's big release Joker would you be
linked at the end I go over the entire
movie and give my thoughts on it so it's
definitely worth checking out if you
want something else to watch after this
you want to come chat to me on Twitter
then make sure you follow me a
definition whitey and if you want to
join my discord to talk about movies TV
shows comic books and games then make
sure you click on the link in the
description below you've got an awesome
community and it's the best way to stay
up to date with the channel so hopefully
I see you over there after this also
just one let you know that we're
currently giving away a free copy of
spider-man far from home on blu-ray and
all you have to do to be in with a
chance of winning is to like this video
make sure that you subscribe to the
channel and leave your thoughts on the
Captur in the comment section below
but when it will be chosen at random on
October the 15th and the blu-ray we
shipped out from then to forget surprise
it's the best of luck to everyone who
takes part this is a channel for people
who are never missing television so if
that's the kind of thing you like you
need to subscribe to definition thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
you've been the best and I'll see you
next time take care peace
[Music]
[Music]